you'll see people bring up toxic
masculinity and a lot of times people
bring it up because they just hate
masculinity so they say you know all
masculinity is toxic but there is a
toxic kind of masculinity right there is
a way where men who have basically have
no good Role Models just decide to
perform to try to pretend they're Conan
the Barbarian or something like that and
it's very silly just toxic stupidity
yeah yeah it always looks like you're
overcompensating for something yeah yeah
right so if I mean I I sort of almost
reject this concept of toxic masculinity
because I feel like it needlessly
genders because you have Behavior
because I have am I toxically masculine
but I feel like how do you really feel I
feel like there definitely is toxic
masculinity I don't think all
masculinity together
yeah I mean some people tell me that you
kind of like blame women a lot it's like
you put like a lot of that's a toxic
masculinity where are you kind of I
blame yeah you blame women like you have
this like I I don't blame women it's
like you tell their lie you kind of
create this image in a woman at bat and
you continuously put it out there for
young men to like be like oh I don't
want to get married like I will just
date women for like as long as I want
why not that you don't want to get
married no no no why not oh all right
one two three one all right 1v7 okay
um well so
I I'm not opposed to necessarily having
a life partner but there there are there
are certain
sorry I'm sorry Michael there are
certain realities when it comes to to
marriage that from the male perspective
make it seem uh risky oh only from the
male perspective because I can feel like
well it's also men are female
perspective how so I think you've never
been in love I feel like yeah if you're
very at risk factor I feel like it goes
both ways okay they're turning on me
well it's but to your point Brian you
you know you make a good amount of money
you the way the judicial system works if
a woman divorced you she could take a
bunch of your money she could take your
kids so there's a risk but my question
is if you're already going to have a
life partner which sounds I'm sorry to
say kind of gay like it's not it's not
gendered it's not traditional thank you
for saying that it's just so if you're
gonna do that anyway why and but you
want to protect against divorce why not
just marry a woman who's not going to
get divorced
So you you're saying like well if you
find the a great woman that you know
that's no not even just that I'm saying
because you know you could find the most
wonderful woman in the world and I don't
know someday something goes off in her
brain and she totally turns on you but
what if you create the structures such
that you're not going to get divorced
I'll give you an example I'm Catholic my
wife and I cannot get divorced she could
murder me that would be her way out of
the marriage but we can it is not
possible for us to get divorced now if
you let's say you're not Catholic yet
and maybe you don't you know you have
you haven't worked through these things
maybe what did you say yes
what if before you get married you sign
a prenup but not the kind of prenup now
not the kind of prenup where you say
okay in case we get divorced you know we
get 50 50. what if you sign a prenup
that says if you divorce I will kill you
yeah I'll kill you whoever brings the
divorce forfeits everything that's
called that's the Knowles prenup and
then you're and then you're safe you're
not going to take your kids you're not
going to take your money and you get to
be married you should not have a life
partner sure I mean I've I I'd love to
bring on like a family attorney to ask
him questions about this but kind of
what I've heard in my understanding when
it comes to prenuptial agreements is
that oftentimes they can be thrown out
and they don't I I don't think prenups
can apply to uh post marriage so you can
protect your assets that you've
acquired pre-marriage I could be totally
off base here but I've heard prenups can
get thrown out someone could say oh I
was assigned to the under duress blah
blah it's unfair it's um there's a
specific term for it that's uh evading
me right now it's um but is that why you
don't want to get married because you're
afraid of the divorce potentially I'm
afraid of woman Why Not Just Dance
issues
Michael and the girls here
with you Brian
um like if you dated another successful
woman wouldn't that fear kind disappear
because then if anything it's like you
know she could be scared of you what if
she's more stupid money or something
what if she's making more money than you
are yeah like why are we just social
media you want a wife right I mean you
you want to not apparently not maybe he
wants to be he wants a life partner like
he wants a life partner yeah well you're
right okay
you know what's big no virtual virtual
girlfriends yeah actual wives
or is it virtual yeah he wants a dog
that speaks English yeah
and that he wouldn't take a thing in the
future now you can have a virtue it's
like an AI but it's interesting
to us and we can figure it out yeah
we'll figure out all your levels I
really want to get to the root of this
problem yeah I I just I
I don't see the the benefits don't well
this is why I ask don't you want a wife
companion there I can have a companion
and not be married and I'm not a fan of
the government so I don't want the
government involved in my life someone
more than 10 years you're gonna be
really good
well not that's only some states not all
states have common law marriage
California we do I don't know how long
no California does not have common law
marriage
my parents are by that
Google it
I haven't been dating since 2001. so
here Colorado Iowa Kansas Montana New
Hampshire Oklahoma Rhode Island South
Carolina Texas Utah and DC
those are the only uh according to this
Sterling you're very quick Google search
yeah it's I think it's a minority of
states that have common-law marriage but
yes that is a risk factor in those
States if if you are cohabitating with
somebody and you almost treat your
relationship as if you're married then
you are basically in the eyes of the law
you are married
uh luckily in California which I don't
know how much longer I'm going to stay
here
um I'm probably going to get canceled by
proxy because Michael's on the show but
um uh just kidding but maybe kidding I
don't know you probably the Franchise
Tax Board is going to come and evict you
probably please scary stuff um so I
don't have anything against for other
people that's great I just I've sort of
looked at the the numbers I've done the
calculus and it just to me it seems like
here I'll put the math here here I've
done the math you know 50 of marriages
end in divorce and the stats I've seen
80 of divorces are initiated by women
and so when I say it it's bad for the
man Devore um the the negative
consequences of divorce typically tend
to disproportionately impact men they
can impact women but I mean I think 97
of it's like 97 of alimony payments go
from men to women so there there are
some concerns there financially and then
just you have the government involved
and then it can be quite contentious and
then not only is there the consideration
in terms of splitting your assets but
then you have lawyers involved and and I
don't have anything necessarily wrong
perhaps from a religious perspective
with marriage but when the state's
involved and I think we
ought to perhaps rewrite marriage laws
to perhaps incentivize men to get
married again because you have no fault
divorce yeah and um
what's the other thing and then um you
know your wife could cheat on you and
then take half your I think under
certain circumstances if you can prove
it in a courtroom that perhaps you
shouldn't be on the hook for alimony if
there's been some infidelity for example
you're saying so that you could dump
your wife if she cheats on you
yes without any Financial hurts yeah
worried about like something gonna
happen bad like when would you just like
you have no trust and faith and I think
it's the society let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question so
how many people get married and they
think hey this is the person I love
we're going to be together forever
and then you you hear that divorce rate
it's like 50 of marriages end in divorce
I think when people get married very
young right but isn't that the best time
to get married
I didn't get married young though I've
only been married now about five years
but I should have gotten married younger
it's one of my quasi regrets in life but
some of the best marriages I've ever
seen were people who got married 20
years old or 22 or 23 years old I just
wonder Brian because all the objections
you're raising are completely legit sure
I just wonder if
you you are looking at an alternative it
doesn't really exist that's illusory
because if you're thinking okay I'm
gonna have more freedom
if I don't get married I don't know if
that's true you know if you're always in
one of these situations even if you're
just dating where you think well where
are we where do we stand is he going to
leave me is this that is in a marriage
in a proper marriage all that is gone
and you see you think I had a bad day I
got in a fight with my wife I didn't do
the laundry whatever doesn't matter
especially if you believe in marriage
like marriage really is you say this is
an institution defined by real things I
made a covenant before God and the
political Community I signed up with the
government they're going to take my
money if I break this Covenant and that
actually it seems like it puts
limitations on you but it actually gives
you a ton of freedom because you can
think oh
I'm here we're in this there's no
there's no getting out there's no way
out but through and so we're just going
to make this thing work I I find it's a
very freeing experience what if you also
meet someone and she's like I want to
get married and you're in love with this
girl is it a deal breaker for you
I have not crossed that so it hasn't
found that that road yet but um I don't
know I mean my my thinking on this is
just you should never sign a contract
with someone who is rewarded for
breaking it and in today's day and age
often times if you
break the marriage contract you there
are certain Financial benefits that you
can reach these people get married in
another country and then you don't have
to passport prosely up
I think Japan maybe actually you know
what's happening in Japan because women
can't find there's not enough guys so
there's a thing where they have one
woman wedding because all these girls
want to get married Tokyo here I come
you know what Michael you've convinced
me to get married in fact Eric if you
can hide this
um
Tatum what oh gosh you pull it out will
you marry me too where'd you just get
that from like last time you reached for
it you just had that ready I had it
ready he knew you were coming he already
knew Tatum
will you marry me
yeah okay put it
thank you Michael you're the best
wingman ever congratulations
Brian I will be divorcing you at the end
of this podcast this is wonderful all
right can can you do a little uh Beyonce
all right okay look at that
nice some people in the back all right
Tatum Atlas okay cool
um
what what's this she's keeping the last
name wait are we hyphenating no no no no
no no no no no they're both Gonna Know
You're Not Gonna Keep your last name but
then our family's name runs out yeah
there's two girls only two girls yeah
the only two girls well that's the way
things shake out right I mean your your
family's name is either going to be your
husband's name or your father's name or
why because that's what your last name
is